anything you can do on a snowboard you
could do it on mountain board I love the
feeling of being in nature and charging
down the mountain I wanted to keep that
feeling all year around so we built
what's called a mountain board
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
my name is Jason Lee and I'm creative
director for NBS mountain ribs have been
mountain boarding for 27 years a
mountain board is a combination of a
skateboard a snowboard even a mountain
bike all rolled into one to create the
feeling of snowboarding on land so in
the early 90s my friend and I decided to
build a mountain board when we started
making them we really had no idea about
any manufacturing techniques whatsoever
we'd go to auto parts stores we go to
junkyards and piece together these
things to you know make a functioning
board watching an onboarding grow from
literally our garage to a global
phenomenon is incredibly satisfying
there are mountain boarders and probably
over 30 countries right now it was
really important for us from the very
beginning to make sure that it was not
just a product it was a sport
it is believed or not very easy to do
the coolest thing about it is that you
can go out on an adventure anywhere
you're at so you don't have to travel
hours and hours or days to go someplace
clue you can ride a mound board anywhere
you desire and write it on grass dirt
pavement you can read it on dirt roads
BMX tracks it's virtually limitless
mountain boarding has brought a lot of
friends into my life and just kind of a
feeling of community it gives me a sense
of purpose to get outdoors and maybe
create some jumps and being able to
bring mountain boarding to people around
the country around the world is a
fantastic feeling
[Music]
you